yo what's up guys this is prestige here
and hello this is the 16th I believe
episode in my hair Bon Jovi hair brown
Survival Series and yeah I've done some
slight renovations I finished this I
gotten it enchanted iron pickaxe
efficiency one i crafted another portal
so yeah we're going to go to the nether
so that's gonna be cool and rather right
here let's just get prepared and am i
doing let's make a chest and a crafting
table and let's get us some more wood so
we're going to be going into the nether
and i know this might be my last episode
of the hair Bang Theory since Heron
Heron to is since uh heroine doesn't is
a modloader only mod and currently I am
used forged to download all my mods and
forge is a lot more used or that's what
it appears to be to me I'm not that
heavy intent on mod so i'm not sure but
that's what it seems like so I'm might
be ending the just calling it urban
series in urban series and I might start
calling it something else like just
survival or our divine RPG survival
something like that and yes I'm going to
be doing that and we're gonna go to the
nether so I don't know this might be
last I'm not sure what I want to do you
see I just don't know if I should yeah I
don't know what to do so hopefully we
won't get viciously murdered the for a
second when we step into the nether and
okay okay we're not getting viciously
murdered that's good let okay so before
we get smack attacked by muggins black
well because the entire netherworld is
wanting and I'm going to make a nice
little huts for us to live in
and I'm getting some hard lag why am I
getting such hard lag stop it I don't
like you in psych we might have to turn
the rendition so tiny that might be okay
well we're going to keep busy it's just
so bad like I it said that face blocks I
don't so this will be a good size for
our little Hut and we can retreat to
hear any time and invaded by evil people
I also I don't optifine so that's going
to be a sorry that's going to be
limiting d abilities oh my gosh stop it
so build you up and like that so now we
can lay down our crafting table and we
can craft ourselves a door I don't think
there's anybody you can break the open
door and we can store any goods right
there and let's go explore dude dude
dude I'm going to want some another XO
now there also are I came here mainly to
there are many oh you see like this
there are many oars ah that you can pick
up and they are very good for crafting
better armor since they are easy to get
they spawn like a good spawning ok let's
try turning normal there we go we got
some glycerin I can pick up some glow
stand go since I was cool
and yet so there are three new mobs I
believe in this ah there there there I
parent those are the things we want to
stay away from since they uh they shoot
arrows and they will kill you in one and
get Oh kinase are they locking on to me
break hopefully not Oh Oh Frick oh gosh
yeah they were ok they can't get up here
but one of their error shots will kill
me in if I had no armor so wildfires are
definitely the most thing to be like
afraid of in this new nether we also got
hell spiders and some the scorchers i
think so i think scorcher the other
thing and he'll spiders are something to
look out for and I think the Scorchers
aren't too bad i think their aim sucks
and there's a hell spider has a 120
health status shoot an arrow that is six
damage critical it yeah definitely go
for it quits let's try and ring it with
all my arrows inside on too many and
then we'll go in for the kill those are
instantly aggroed mobs or the hell
spider is so all right I definitely
going to want a way to get back up go
not sure I taking out now there's on
pigmen won't bother us in this be better
than so we're hell spider let's go I
think you can set me on fire if you hit
me so I'm going to give my best to keep
you at guard to be at bay be back foul
demon how yeah this is a sub set me on
fire baby yo would you drop you
seriously you drop netherrack Oh nope
there's a wildfire bail be gone from me
while tire on offense quarters and some
they give me purple blaze and that is
what I want look mad oh it's a Magna
cube one health and it's a friendly mom
I think you may be good so yeah yeah
yeah Oh bigger bag cute yeah yeah magma
cream today these things work like
zombies are podido vanilla mob so it's
chill also get some XP that's my little
HUD right there um more glowstone that
looks like some risky clothes time and I
get you and some gravel is that what up
that big big boy over there once I
avoiding him yr wildfires like Frank
there they spawn so much
I'll be not alerting you of my presence
anybody I should pop you around me sort
out I got some more blood gems over
there so we're gonna pick those up have
a lot more cobble to get up there see I
don't see any no but I'm over there what
I think I think is the other ores is
just pledged em all this is the other
work wow wow wow oh I think if I touch
this or I get hurt nether or that's what
I was going for but i only get one goes
to well that's some religious stuff oh
okie dokes moving on haha there we go
get old blood gems now see if I get some
purple blazes I can craft a fairly good
sword I can grab this orbit just blood
gems but with some purple blades I can
craft probably's powder something like
that and crash better stuff so I want
that is my oh there's my little hot cool
all right okay let's not drop down to
this lava and there's this stuff so
let's go one right here so in case we
follow you a little bit of leeway
and let's build over to ourselves and
then should be safe nice we can also
move up in this and so we can just keep
collecting other accents and a button
into another rack is never too bad so
kind of I want to find a nether fortress
because place lazasar good for them
blaze rods so anything up here and gives
us the route of roof of the nether
I want to be careful edges I guess more
over there anything going to go for that
up not maybe not not too scared of gas
just that it is going too far away Oh
Frick oh free today's kind of far away
so that plus trying to get there or with
a gas not the best plan so I think
you're right here say do you have nine
blood gems only have one another right
over them so gonna need it tunnel our
way down now with the tunnel these guys
guys up we got some stuff over the air
that is a wildfire okay good I blood gem
yeah so these are both fairly common
spawning [ __ ] oh there's my good man
pick that sucks efficiency one on that
bad boy
all right I've always found neither
right in north of two well then okie
dokie so another way is the red so those
are blood gems that now there's a
wildfire really don't need 200 here
spider I'm need some bread Oh Frick is
on the ceiling go to too true just
looking around for some of the goods oh
there we go some other right okay okay
we can we can get there here are some
time pick okay so that's going to be
that's a no goes home no my not here so
we can see where we're going can start
going down
a little bit of a drop off with some
fire yes
you
sorry about that guys just little
talking about some planes weird that
another right go where did I see that
other right right at five mode there it
is haha f5 mode working for us so this
definitely takes a lot longer to mine
boo boo boo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
get another right we have seven to the
right awesome get a wildfire over there
he'll spider right there how the spider
drops for your netherrack that is be
some BS man vs so we try going that I
think yeah I think you can manage not to
a growth a spider will be good
white gravel looks a lot different how
does another gravel look different just
gravel okay I think you can manage not
however the house later I'm assuming
he's fine getting hit by lava guys get a
little more f5 there is life I'd so good
guys there we go get some more all right
and I think uh Scorchers are the kind of
rare oh I guess what thats a guest it's
gas I think scorchers are kind of rare
um let's find my way back up this is not
only that guy oh oh ow oh crap to do
grab my piss them off okay what's down
to here
I think I found my way across yeah all
right oh lets your guess I kind of want
to just get out of another crack
wildfire kind of just get see a wildfire
is what we're looking at oh crap oh well
I was gonna plant using the failsafe
come on the dot oh my gosh perfection oh
my gosh who's a beast half a heart oh my
god that was some risky stuff I thought
how I was all around hi files for
risking it all and making it out alive
should probably wait a little long for
my health provision rate since it seems
as it's nighttime it does appear to be
the darkness let's hope nothing blows us
up hmm think we're good
now i'm fairly sure you cook yeah i
think you can craft this at all usually
have an or you get there we go neither i
think it now i think with the nether
right you have to come put it with
shadow bricks which is a mixture of
rupee and am light and mo write
something like that so we probably won't
be doing that anytime soon but i'm going
to put that in there since you can make
a ball and also you and move you with
you the magma cream also oh ok
sorry my phone is in the process of
blown up so there's the blood gem sword
which is nine male damage infinite uses
this i think has less than nine is a six
so the actually i think i'm going to get
that since I know it can I make armor
out of it do I need something else to
make armor out of it don't know lets up
some of their crafting recipes are
different than normal stuff so i'm not i
don't think you can make stuff out of
blood gems ya know yeah i guess i've no
idea ro against another writing gets
that's cool and we have a Ledge m sword
so that leaves better it also sorry if
you have three diamond swords you can
make a slime sword and sign balls you
can make slime sword which is I think
infinite uses below and let's see how
much you do you might use six that's a
three damage preset is much better and
we can I can yeah this infinite so
that's good if I had the blaze Pat blue
purple blaze powder I could make a
better sword with a one blood jen plus
the other stuff we have another ingots
yeah like see if we go in here and we
try and grab no I want that yeah I'm
getting like a blood tastes feeling my
mouth that's nasty I don't think I can
what the nether right bricks
um okay I guess you can crash them into
that oh is this the right chunk oh I
think the things are made out of shadow
bars and other right chunks like say I
do that I'll crap I can't craft it back
um well let's has something always just
get more to the right something I'm fine
okay kamek sort of it nope all right
well we now know that okay oh I can only
kill like a pig if I didn't have a tons
of XP i would try let's see let's okay
so i know a lot of the infinite use
weapons you can't enchant normally so oh
wow you can make sure Atkins out of iron
ingots huh that's cool ah let's see i'm
gonna need three of these and boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom there we go and
i'm so over staff plus ten keep the 10
and we'll move you won't have something
to do with this room
um yeah let's put the block but no it
falls dang it can't do that I think of
this block okay so yeah I'd also
mushroom now see I grabbed these books I
can you can chant books so say I throw a
book in there let's get slow five is
your chain five I don't want feather
fall in five this might so say we throw
you in there in there we get with smite
one accepts might one is not good so
knocking is that I would have liked
sharpness wait we have smite three fire
aspect and thorns um so I respect only
bows no it is not
um sure wow I love line that drying my
levels and now if we go find a mob now
I'm not too worried by 99 is still it's
more than nothing but well i kind of
wanted to kill a crab they love to
settle for a pig his 10 health of is
gonna kill one hit no matter what oh we
get cooked bacon yes all this sort of
all this this sort is great now a good
idea to do is to get looting I'm not
going to find one of those guys since
I'm still only it would take 40 hit over
40 hits for me to kill them so actually
I saw this on the guide with the on the
guide to kill a king crab your knee
where you're first going to do is build
a three by three hole that is let's just
be safe okay I can hit them there
I'm going to put you right there and
then you just get the king crab was 500
health whose chill with us and you push
them no no go in there king crab king
crab going there you sure she's not
fault can you not fall into that oh my
gosh way so fat okay we're gonna need to
make it bigger hey iron that's cool uh
with four by four work at least he's
really easy to push he doesn't put up a
struggle that all here a skeleton oh
crap I okay there we go and now it's /
small I'm not even hit him anymore well
the fire damage is nothing good Tommo
vain this would be so much easier if you
just stay put i'm gonna place this so i
can hit a media there we go and because
infinite uses it's a great spam
who put a brooder cannon myself can cry
in here i use it i only get six and yeah
his Lucien burn even if he's on fire
since I'm not killing blah blah so
that's good just be safe let's just but
the fire died out by the time I fire air
early stuff I can't tell if he's a great
on us you're not trying to do this oh my
gosh you dropped me nothing thank you so
much well this will be our will be our
king crab hole and I'm gonna make this
with sand sometime I'll make a sign this
is king crab cool
ah let's take about 16 hits to kill this
guy ah I've killed him the stone sword
bit small if I spam he should be able to
cut back if I click fast enough yeah
there we go nice a crab claw no idea
what that used for Mardi at all so ya
budu little 14 is he killing these
things like gives me tons of XP dozen
guys men leaving the king crab all right
there let's check uh oh wow this video
has been going on very long okay you
guys have been getting some long videos
all right well I hope you guys all
enjoyed my name is my name is prestige
yeah the studio is pretty logical
carried away I hope you'll enjoy nether
adventures all the good stuff hooky new
sword so um if you like this then give
it a like comment subscribe um strike
and you've got all the way to the end of
the video I feel like you do one of them
because if you like the video that much
and I greatly appreciate it so until
next time goodbye